hello and welcome back to our channel
today we're going to be talking about an
anime called problem children are coming
from another world aren't they choosing
to leave behind everything in pursuit of
their personal goals human teenagers
are is to an alternate reality the
little garden where different races with
different powers or gifts reside there
they meet black rabbit a girl with
rabbit ears making her a judge master
that enforces rules and order due to
being servants of the little garden's
creator she explains the place's logic
to them the little garden revolves
around gift games that challenge players
with games of varying danger while
betting something in exchange for
rewards if they win black rabbit also
invites them into her own community of
players making their way to a rural
village in the east black rabbit leaves
asuka and yol with her community's
leader jin after noticing izayui
separated from them in search of fun as
the rest wait for black rabbit and
izay's return over some drinks they're
approached by a mysterious man named
gaspar a beast man who's also the leader
of a community he invites the girls to
join his community along with black
rabbit to convince them he makes fun of
how jin's community was forced to become
a no-name after losing an undeniable
challenge from the tyrannical demon
lords of the little garden resulting in
the community losing their formal name
and banner this has left the remaining
members to be gin black rabbit and
around 120 children with ages 10 and
below making winning their banner and
name back difficult at the same time
black rabbit finding izayoi after he
defeats a water god explains their
situation to him in the hopes the three
can help and he agrees asuka suspicious
of gaspar's claim that his community has
won all gift games that involve staking
their banner uses her gift to command
him to reveal how it turns out that
gaspar has kidnapped women and children
from other communities to subdue and
blackmail them into doing their bidding
however breaking his promises and
killing them off eventually infuriated
the girls challenged him to a gift game
the next day
after izayoi and black rabbit reunite
with the others the group visits shiro
yasha a demon lord from the thousand
eyes an extremely large trade community
to appraise the children's gifts unlike
others of her kind shiro yasha has
chosen to use her strength for peace
becoming the floor master or guardian of
the east side of the little garden they
decide to challenge her to a gift game
that joe wins by befriending a griffin
and overcoming its trial using her gift
of taking the powers of other animals
she's befriended to ultimately save
herself from shiro yasha the three
learned that they come from different
times on earth and earn gift cards that
can store their gifts and list their
names with izayos stating unknown by
beating the water god izayoi receives an
endless water supply from a water tree
that he lets the no names use the girls
used this water to bathe together after
which asuka borrows a dress from black
rabbit that gives its wearer an
additional aura of protection the next
day all of them are brought to gaspa's
residence which has been newly revamped
with a tangling creeper forest and
beastification magic the rules however
handicap the three to be unable to use
their gifts forcing them to defeat
gaspar instead using a designated weapon
after being confronted by gaspar who has
turned into a demon tiger jinn deduces
from the surrounding magic to be a
vampiric and demon nature suspecting the
involvement of another party involved
recognizing their designated weapon to
be a cross sword speared in the wall yo
distracts gaspar as asuka orders jin to
run away alone first however
inadvertently cutting herself off with
him when joe returns injured and
collapses asuka returns to the residence
sets the place on fire and lures him out
of the forest recalling how black rabbit
had shooted her to use her gift in
controlling others gifts as well she
uses the creepers in restraining gaspar
commands the sword to give her its power
and kills him winning the game this
causes all his slaves to be freed before
jinns vowed to take down the demon lords
angering the vampire who cast the curse
on gaspa bringing yo back to their
territory an unnamed man with black and
blonde hair arrives at shiro yasha's
place while yo continues to recover
black rabbit discusses with izayui about
their next step to rescue leticia a
pureblood vampire who was the former
demon lord and comrade jin had
previously talked about however their
conversation is interrupted by the
vampire who assisted gaspar who is none
other than leticia herself she
apologizes for causing them trouble as
she only wishes to know the extent of
the children's powers but concludes that
their gifts are too unrefined to manage
the community and wants black rabbit to
disband it as the gift game wagering her
had been cancelled leticia's owner the
blonde and blackhead man named leias at
shiroyasha's place decides to attack the
no-names using a gorgon that can turn
people to stone with its rays leticia
sacrifices herself to protect asuka
after black rabbit discovers she's lost
her divinity and becomes an ordinary
vampire instead during a gift game with
izayui members of leias's community
called perseus are sent to retrieve her
and izay stops black rabbit from
attacking them choosing to speak with
leos instead at shiro yasha's instead of
betting black rabbit on the line they
choose to challenge paseos to a jewel
after izay earns titles from winning
against legendary monsters giving them
the right to challenge any community to
a gift game despite being a no name the
gift game involves invading leos's
fortress and only those who can reach
him without being detected will but they
lose their rights to challenge him
however the guards all have gifts
invisible helmets izayui comes with a
plan of having asuka distract most of
the guards using the water tree while yo
gives way to him and jin as they sneak
past joe helps izayoi and jin obtain one
of the replicas and steal the real
helmets using echolocation instead of
confronting them leias unleashes his
trump card a former demon lord under his
control turning all outside the coliseum
into stone and attacks izayoi who easily
overpowered it with his strength and
defeats it by destroying its gifts with
his unknown ability although leias
admits defeat and relinquishes leticia
izayoi gives him a chance to fight back
in a fist fight raising the stakes of
the game where paseos must wager their
banner when they lose he exiles leias
from being part of the thousand eyes
league taking down their banner the
paseo's constellation from the night sky
leticia returns to the no-name community
as a maid as gratitude for saving her as
they celebrate together izayoi vows to
put their banner in the sky as well
waking up they find a letter that black
rabbit has been trying to keep a secret
an invitation to the nativity of the
salamander festival at salamandra
located in the north east district of
the northern region in celebration of
the coronation of their new leader 11
year old sandra who's also a friend of
jin
finding out that there will be gift
games involved despite the high
traveling costs yo asuka
run away to the festival with jin and a
little fox girl named lily leaving a
note behind to black rabbit threatening
to leave the community should she not
catch them in a day seeking shiro
yasha's help in getting to salamandra yo
is caught by black rabbit as izayoi and
asuka escape to the festival grounds as
a chase ensues black rabbit is
challenged to a game where the winning
party can order the loser to do any one
thing of their choice after izayui
brings down a building that leads the
game to a draw military policemen of
salamandra led by sandra's brother
mandra arrive to confront them while
with shiro yasha yo is invited to
participate in a gift game tournament
known as battle of the creators passing
the preliminaries to advance to the
finals since no one got hurt during the
game between black rabbit and izay
sandra decides to let them go unpunished
to mandra's disappointment in his hatred
for the no names as an additional
punishment shiro yasha requests that
they protect sandra by slaying the demon
lord meanwhile asuka gets on good terms
with the fairy from a community called
rattanfenger going to an art exhibition
where she's amazed by an armor made by
the community themselves however she's
attacked by rats that she can't control
having to be saved by leticia instead
since her gift of authority doesn't work
on someone stronger than her asuka
figures that someone is manipulating the
rats and tries to become stronger
growing jealous of izayois and yo's
physical prowess during a meeting shiro
yasha lets black rabbit judge the battle
of creators the following day upon the
announcement of the remaining
participants communities asuka is
surprised to see ratan finger in the
list beside no name salamandra and
willow the wisp shiro yasha explains
that the ratan finger the one who
manipulates rats is related to a
community called the pied piper of
hamelin who once worked under a demon
lord that summoned 200 demons and led to
a community called grim grimoire which
got disbanded after losing in a gift
game after figuring out its roots
everyone concludes that with the
assistance of ratan wenger the demon
lord of grim grimwa will attack at the
nativity of the salamander as they
dismiss their meeting shiro yasha
cautions everyone to be on their guard
for any spy from ratan finger and
protect sandra making asuka doubt the
identity of the little fairy with her
the battle of the creators begins where
yo is pitted against a member from the
willow the wisp community faced with an
immortal demon yo surrenders although
she could ask someone for help from her
community not wanting to rely on others
just then black ghias roles start
falling from the sky inviting everyone
to join a game the aim of the game
forces players to break the false law
and expose the true legend as well as
forming a barrier around shiro yasha
that hinders her participation in the
game above the arena are the members of
the community the pied piper of hamelin
is hoping to find their leader randomly
picks an opponent and ends up fighting
wesser the embodiment of the wesser
river from the fairy tale leticia and
sandra also battled against pest a demon
lord of the black plague in the story as
asuka yo and jin trying to figure out
the cause of shiro yasha's inability to
join the game rather than the embodiment
of the rats from the story and the ones
who attacked asuka in the art exhibit
gains control over the citizens of
salamandra using her flute asuka makes
jin and yo run away wanting to be rotten
but loses and is lost as chaos reigns
over salamandra black rabbit uses her
authority as judge master to put the
game on hold and ask both parties to
have a meeting the no names tried to
confirm the details of the game from
pest who's also the community leader and
the game's host but the rules are
confirmed to be just and being followed
due to the lack of details while trying
to find a schedule to resume the game
pest reveals that she's spreading
pathogens throughout the city to make
people ill threatening the no names to
join their community grim grimoire of
hamelin if they want to live deducing
that this is a new community wanting
more manpower izayoi bends the rules to
allow black rabbit to participate in the
game as well postponing the game to a
week's time meanwhile asuka is being
held captive in a dark cave along with a
little fairy the lost souls of the 130
children that died in the story of the
pied piper of hamelin appear asking
asuka to help them end the false law of
the ratan finger in exchange for their
armor dean if she can make it submit to
her in a game after four days yo and the
citizens of salamandra are feeling the
symptoms of the black plague izayue
visits yo in her room to help her
alleviate her boredom trying to find out
the truth behind the fairy tale due to
the more being summoned from different
timelines many things happened
differently but there would be some
unchanged although there would still be
the question of whether the pied piper
of hamlin they're facing is the same
story they knew as the black plague is
unable to kill the children in the story
in a limited time which creates a
contradiction remembering that the black
plague occurred in the 14th century
after the little ice age due to the
weakening of the sun and that shiro
yasha has control over the sun's
activity he realizes that the
prerequisite for the game will not be
met if she joins the game since the
black plague which is a necessary part
of the game will not be able to occur
when the sun is active izayoi also
records the stained glass depicting the
pied pipe of hamelin scattered across
the town in the story following the
riddle they should break all the stained
glass except for the one that depicts
the true legend behind the pied piper on
the day of the game izayoi and the other
scatter around salamandra breaking
stained glasses of the false law the
grim grimoire of hamelin summons the
village of hamlin in a panic changing
the locations of the stained glasses and
doubling their powers wesser with his
divinity activated tries to take on
izayoi black rabbit and sandra fight
hand in hand against pest while jin and
the others fight against ratan and her
ceramic monsters just then asuka saves
them with her deen at her command izayoi
continues to fight against wesser the
real pied piper of hamelin revealing
that the pie piper of hamline appeared
during the time the black plague was
getting weak and that the others were
added later and were modeled after the
black plague ultimately provoking wesser
to fight and be defeated meanwhile using
dean asuka battles against the rotten
storms and wins despite allowing her to
play one additional song to control dean
to by time pest tells sandra and black
rabbit of her identity as the embodiment
of the resentment and revengeful desire
of the 80 million people that died from
the black plague wanting to have revenge
on the sun and hence shiro yasha sensing
her two comrades death her patience
snaps spreading a dark red wing of
plague that kills anyone it touches to
stop the never-ending flow of sickness
black rabbit transports the fighters to
the moon palace weakening pests power
asuka commands the full potential of the
spear of indra that black rabbit lent
her to defeat pest thereby ending the
game after the battle asuka meets with
the children who tell asuka of another
interpretation of the pied piper of
hamlin in the story the 130 children
left their parents home to follow the
pine piper to a city where they would
build their own community the
rattanfenger deciding to return to their
time they leave her in charge of dean
and their
131st member the little fairy the asuka
names mirren in the sanamandra palace
izayue confirms his claims to mandara
that sanamandra had invited the demon
lord pest to the festival staging her
defeat which can concrete sandra's claim
to her position as salamandra spreads
the news of their victory against the
demon lord with no excuse for the
actions mandra let izayoi take his life
in exchange that sandra is kept
unknowing but izayo tells him that he
would rather sanamandra to be the first
to aid them in their time of need
instead at the no name community
everyone attempts to re-fertilize their
land with the help of merun and dean
amid happy toil a letter flows down
before izayoi with a mysterious seal on
top
so this is it for today's video if you
like the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time